Hello, good afternoon, everyone. I hope
the sound is correct.
Good evening to those of you who are here in
Spain. We are going to start making a
presentation related to
perioperative analgesia in laboratory animals.
The first question that is always only
asked in these cases is usually
whether the objectives that we set ourselves
during analgesia or
anesthesia in laboratory animals are
the same as those that we should set in
human or veterinary patients and
probably the answer is that the
objective in both cases is to ensure an
adequate anesthetic and analgesic plan  and
therefore we ended up using
practically the same types
of drug combinations, in this case,
for example, analgesics, although it is
true that the objectives are very
different, he always stated that in the case
of a patient, the objective
will always benefit the patient
while  that in the case of auditory
malaise this usually does not usually
It should be thought
which are the most appropriate techniques,
therefore, practically those
that we are seeing in the field of
human and veterinary clinics use
practically the same
analgesic drugs and the same combinations,
another different issue that we have to
make different adjustments
and this is largely due to  because the
processes by which pain is
perceived in animals,
specifically in mammals, is
basically identical, that is, we have
a signal transduction or
translation mechanism where
a series of factor substances are also involved
that we can modulate or control,
for example with  anti-inflammatories
our videos
subsequently ineffective signal transmission
to the spinal cord that we can
block with local anesthetics in the
spinal cord there is a
tiba news signal modulation system that
increases or attenuates the perception of
pain in animals and where
we really  can  We can also establish
analgesic mechanisms, for example, by
administering
local anesthetic opioids or substances for 10 vidals and
finally the fourth process is the
perception of that notification translated
into a signal that we understand as pain
and again we can use drugs,
therefore basically we are going to use the
same  drugs and techniques based
predictably we understand the same
types of pain perception processes
throughout the presentation we are going to
see a series of vignettes like the one we
see at the bottom in which
they indicate the publications from
which we have been able to extract  the
information that we are showing and
we want at the end where the information
can be obtained through a
web page.
This web page is called the website of
animal pain and its treatment and in it,
for example, we can see aspects such
as current recommendations for
control assessment  of pain in
providers or, for example, the
recognition  nto of this value also in
laboratory animals in another
public optimization when we
see them later,
the main problem
we really have in the treatment of pain
is probably derived from its
correct recognition.
There is a statement that
basically indicates that the pain that has  an
animal is really the pain that
we decide as evaluators
because basically because we
will treat the pain of that animal as
long as we understand
or perceive that the animal is in pain and
therefore if we consider that the animal is
not in much pain we are not going to
act accordingly
there are numerous scales or really
perhaps not so many because many of them
are not validated, that is, they cannot be
reproduced in different environments in
different laboratories, and most of
the scales refer to
species in a specific clinical field, that is,
for example, dogs, actress, not for example
here.  on the slide we can  Let's see how
we have one of the first
publications by Firth and Jardín in
which he develops all the first ones used in the so-called
evaluation scale of the value of the
University of Melbourne
and although a great
advance with respect to the absence of this
type of scales  It has really been able to be
improved. We do not see that there are other scales
written in the years following the year
1999 and probably in recent years
we have the scale that
we use most commonly in the case of dogs,
which is the Glasgow scale
and also on the other hand.
Another scale has appeared developed by a
Brazilian group on pain from a Spanish professor,
one that also tries to
assess the level of pain and
animal inductions and, above all, to identify it
so that we can act from a
certain threshold with analgesic drugs.
Society of
American Hospitals has also developed
guidelines for the treatment of pain in dogs.
and cats,
we can say that these are the
species that fundamentally benefited
from, let's say, the interest initially but
also from the further development
of pain from a clinical point of view,
not and in this sense, for example,
we can see that we already look at
relevant aspects in the assessment of pain.
pain such as a loss of
normal behavior on the other hand the
appearance of expressions or
behaviors typical of pain or
associated with pain
the reaction for example to the evacuation
of the wound without a factor that is considered
very important to verify that
an animal really has pain because  It is the point,
let's say, of greatest estimation that guides us
and then also sometimes other
types of physiological parameters.
The problem is when we transfer
this information from some species in
which, due to having been studied more, to other
species in which, well, the
development, let's say, still  it requires a
little more time and work we are going to
p  Here is a very simple example, including
a clinical study, such as
what is the treatment in the case of
cats that attracts attention, and in this
case from a study that we carried out in
Spain, as although all
veterinarians considered that both
dogs  as the cats had a
basically identical perception of
pain and what we saw was that
after asking the same
veterinarians at what level, what
percentage did they treat after surgery, for
example, an architect of mine, as we see in
this case, a mental extraction with
strict or  surgeries to control them from a
certain parakeet we saw how
cats really had inferior treatment in
terms of
the administration of analgesics and
probably also the type of
shellfish administered with respect
to dogs therefore apparently
we are aware of
pain in animals but we did not act
consequently
in this sense, for example, in cats
recently  A valid scale has appeared,
that is to say, that we can use and
in theory we should learn
similar results regardless
of who performs the valuation or in which
country it is carried out, for example, and this was
carried out by the group that said before
descended from an investment in Sao Paulo
de  In fact, it has a very
interesting page that recommends visiting
animal paint, where we can
find different Indians on the
other hand, if we go to the website that
we show at the end, we see the
availability of all these resources and
videos if, for example, we can, we will
see a  example of how they value in this
case an abnormal posture an indicator
of the maximum age level value in the
case of the cat
now let's start a
video tracy you like to start video
list
maybe be peacefully from
resting on the
on its own one  new their own bed
, therefore the most important thing here is to
be able to detect what the
behaviors are  social about the in
second place try to evaluate the
value the give a rating and
subsequently administer the drugs
in the appropriate way it is true that
many times we can anticipate the pain
if we are going to do one or perform a
surgery it is foreseeable that by keeping it
operational for the most part  we need painkillers so much
another important aspect is to
consider the painkillers
have really been effective and have blocked the
pain or made it basically tolerable
here we will see other examples of
abnormal cat postures a posture in
curved at the top for example
versus a
quite different posture  or radically
different from what a cat would have
that is sleeping peacefully and
that typically does not present any
discomfort and is expressing or suffering from
another problem is that when we
administer drugs we sometimes
also obtain abnormal responses or behaviors,
this would be an example of
abnormal behavior  seems  a
punished time that reacts
simply to the administration of
opioids, which is a relatively
described phenomenon in this species and probably
in other species these
anomalous behaviors are not so frequent or are not
seen
therefore to assess pain we
need scales we have already seen
some some so varied from a
score but typically to the extent
two songs how to use
visual analog scales we are going to see another
video of this case a video that we
developed in a studio in our
laboratory where we are going to see the
behavior that
tracy play would have I am an addict  Being in
high school
in this video we
continue, then, that there are systems
that allow pain to be quantified in a
more adequate way. In this same
study, we use, for example,
the dynamometer that we see in the upper part,
this dynamometer basically
allows us to establish a great mechanic
I prefer a normal cat will tolerate a
pressure on the abdomen normally measured in
newtons pain is maintained the
pressure that it will support will be
considerable in integrating this type of
study they are being carried out more and
more in the clinical field probably
in the research field only to
show studies but not in the  scope
that we can say about the control
of laboratory animals of the surgical request
if we look at the results that
we obtained in this case in the data
we see how the cat animals that had
a basal pressure value of
approximately 12 newtons
these levels will decrease after the
surgery in a considerable way in the
control group in less than 5 minutes it is
true that the animals that had been
treated either with the anti-inflammatory
master and jaume lóxica or with antidote at the
end and with another informant of our
video came to show values ​​that
are  decreased with respect to the
control but different from those we
have in the placebo group which
We are beginning to have a more
objective assessment of whether the
analgesics are actually produced in effect,
here we can also determine that this
effect is not completely complete, that is, it
does not reverse the basal situation of an
animal that has nothing
and what happens in rodents in rodents
I think  that all or practically all of us
know the works of paul flynn
in which different behaviors are observed,
for example after
abdominal surgery, typically in the rat
the contraction of the lumbar cutaneous muscle
,
the fall or the arching of the 2 and
we see that in animals that do not  have
received an analgesic the number of
behaviors is significantly
higher than when we administer a
target that we consider to be effective,
for example, in logic at 2 milligrams per
kilo these videos are
also available as we all know at a
symbolic price of one pound so
we can see all of them  the behaviors
explained in the same
tutorial which is surprising  This is the finding
in 2010 by a
research group on pain from the
Yield Land Rhythm Group
at Yale University, which raises a
very interesting hypothesis and that is that animals
pose or have a similar expression of facial pain.
to the one that
people have, so that when an
animal is in pain, what will happen
is that it can show a closure of the
eyes of the matches,
compare it, for example, with what would be
the normal situation, the normal reading of
the eyelids, but also  a
twitch in the nose
also from cuddling
the ears die
normally rotate back and in
some cases also the whiskers have to
flatten this effect is apparently much more
evident in rabbits
compared to mice with which
we are also seeing that it is not
only the  Mice but probably
other rodents and rats, for example
rabbits, can curiously show this effect
at the pi level.  co de karina
and in the cat there has always been talk of the
facial expression of color but it
has never been quantified in terms like the ones
we have here in which we give a
different score depending on these
colors
the ideal would be to have
life teams  as we have for other things and so,
for example,
the dei mouse has recently appeared but it
really was not very effective when it comes to
assessing pain or also other
systems more used in the field
of pain assessment research,
probably still far from their
routine application if it is not for the
specific purpose and therefore
we can conclude that
this facial expression that we are seeing
in this person is very similar to the one that
we can see in rodents and
perhaps we should look at
our  rodents or in these animals if
we try to assess pain
but really what is anesthesia if
we are talking about analgesia the
perioperator  In other words, the awareness
that we administer during the
anesthetic period is basically that we
need the animal to be asleep,
what we call hypnosis, which
is supposed to be analgesia that makes it possible to
tolerate the pain that surgery can produce
and muscle relaxation that
allows the surgeon to work
comfortably and  at the same time also
absence of autonomic responses that
in electrified and
amnesia but really a very important factor is
going to be simple analgesia
whenever there is a procedure that is
potentially the doors in this sense
I think it is interesting to remember that
although the use of  Before
neuromuscular block is quite atypical in
the field of research, it can
occur and a situation can be generated
that we must avoid: it is
a paralyzed animal,
an insufficient anesthetic level,
that is, conscious and that it can perceive the
moment of a rodent, I think
that everyone  you probably know this
movie  ula in Spanish under
elway anesthesia than in English in which he is seen
as a patient under anesthesia
but who is conscious throughout
the surgical procedure a
thoracotomy to perform a coronary bypass
obviously this situation is not
pleasant and is not desirable for this
patient or  for none of our
animals
well where we have to
apply analgesia or analgesics
we can really administer them and in
fact we do it in all phases
of anesthesia
we can administer it during
the preaching period say pre-anesthetic
many times the tranquilizers the
combinations or  energy include, for
example, today during the
induction before we use the
thread for the induction to
sometimes need animals
typically in a maintenance that is
when the painful procedure is going to be performed
and finally we can also
administer them we usually administer it in
the  recovery
The important thing is
that if we know that we are going to perform a
painful procedure, we can
anticipate administering an analgesic
before said procedure occurs and
this always happens.  In all surgery,
another important aspect is that rarely
a single drug produces an
adequate analgesic effect and at the same time
devoid of side effects,
especially if we talk about the
perioperative period with surgery.
Therefore, we understand combining drugs that
allow us to reduce the doses but
maintaining the desired analgesic effect is
what we call the
multimodal session combining different drugs
that are not only almost never from the same pharmacological group,
it is really based on the
use, for example, of an opioid
with inflammation from our video or with
I have a technique from last night
regional greeting  For example,
we have the
Curiously, we also have
old drugs that we have learned to
use in a more appropriate way,
so if we go to a preaching
in medium-large evils,
typically we are going to use a
health agonist, it is like a ship ends one
minute after  life and on the other hand
generally one says it can be the
finest it can be the mental one or others
similar we use it many times
really in rodents it is where
we least tend to use a premedication
as such directly we go to the
administration of anesthetic drugs in
addition  From this combination that we have
indicated, we are typically going to try to
block the inflammatory response and the
pain caused by the
inflammatory response, therefore it is current that we
combine these drugs a
sermon afterward with an enjoyment of
our video that is
normally administered before surgery to  that blocks
that inflammatory response from surgery
and we can also  administer drugs
locally well techniques such as the
epidural but I do it as simple as
sometimes showing the surgical wound or
using other drugs such as ketamine
that provide some affect the
gas in another way
what folds do we use morphine we
are still using it
quite a lot in  europe especially
mint bona is being widely introduced
in recent years and has almost replaced
morphine in many cases it does not
have some advantages practically a
24-hour duration of analgesia and
practically any
surgical procedure does not produce vomiting does not
tend to produce dysphoria  in some species and
therefore it presents some advantages
while it maintains the analgesic effect,
not basically the advantages
derived from
fentanyl, using a drug
device like the previous ones, useful in
many situations in induction of
anesthesia, maintenance of
anesthesia, continuous inclusion and  we have
too  Also other more modern, more expensive drugs such
as the clock in had that
really is a modification of the
content that allows us to administer it
in a pump so that if a form of
infusion is for analgesic effects, the
drugs we use during
anesthesia give way if we leave, for example  Regarding the
use of drugs for rodents,
what we are really going to see is that
we use drugs that are often
related to their duration,
for example, propofol or Tibet in the
sun before, due to the strong mentality, it
is really used very little in Europe
and for the mind in
In fact, in the USA there have been supply problems.
Propofol has a
problem and that is that it is not a drug that
has adequate analgesic properties
, therefore it is sane
for mildly painful anesthesia, but if
we want to
administer propofol to perform surgery,
it is probably very  scarce from the
energetic point of view and we have to
supplement it with analgesic drugs  s
jong
then on the other hand we have the drugs
that we use the most for rodents but
also for other species
fundamentally ketamine with ghana
normally combined with
sedatives ketamine has are physical the same
as there are many of the sedatives such
as the organists of angry receptors
minimum merit and Latina
alternatively can use, for
example, one combined with a
tranquilizer. The problem is that these
opioids are often controlled
by regulations, therefore we
require what we call a prescription for
narcotics and pentobarbital makes them
difficult to care for or relatively
restricted.
again, it is a drug
that has few analgesic properties,
if at all, and other drugs such
as lorethane or anesthetics and
swimming agents, for example, assume that they have
little or no analgesic effect and
that they require the combination or
addition of a drug with said
analgesic properties
Maybe of all these combinations or
drugs to produce anesthesia,
ketamine is not really combined
with other drugs that will produce
the most
appropriate analgesic effects. Ketamine has
analgesic effects.  and it is a very common combination,
for example, among tango
entradon, but they can also use it
in others, it is comfort, or perhaps in the
dog, which also has to be
taken care of because after
historical effects, but in general it is a drug,
a combination based on  It is also
very useful because it provides very adequate analgesia.
An additional effect is that we can
antagonize the praying agents, although it must be
taken into account that at the end of the
surgery there is a residual effect with residual doses
in plasma that
can also provide an additional effect,
but technically they use it.
antagonist reverse the animal from
anesthesia and recover  but
if we go to review, for example, the
last publication of elflein mail or
the last edition of his book on
leftover laboratory animals in the
mouse, we see that we have many
combinations of drugs that can
produce anesthetic effects, but if
we are going to select those that  they
are going to produce
a surgical anesthesia, that is to say, it
allows surgical manipulation of
animal sharps, does not perceive the pain
derived from said manipulation,
we see that we have, for example,
curiously, combinations of
drugs that are going to produce
surgical anesthesia but of very short
duration, for example, only  Five
minutes in the case of alpha csa in the
case of the minor from the Médoc, yes, the
example of propofol or thiopental
, therefore it is not usual, except
for highly contaminated situations,
there are other types of fentanyl-based drugs,
fundamentally when
we can see  here they will produce an
anesthetic effect of about 30 to 40
my  minutes, for example, in these cases here,
for example, also in front of none
commented on a piece of data 40 60 minutes but with
the current that we were saying before that it
is fentanyl, for example, it requires
regulatory control that is sometimes very
restrictive, which limits its usefulness
and finally we have  the combinations
based on that also fundamentally
that they are those that will
again provide a surgical anesthesia of a
normal duration acceptable or generally
required by the researchers and that
probably meets easy access and
at the same time an adequate effect
therefore of  In cases when we
administer anesthetics and we want
this administration to be by
injection, we tend to
use anesthetics in oratories. On the
contrary, it does not have a
very clear analgesic effect and we have to greatly increase the
dose so that our animals do not
react to the surgical stimulus
and sometimes  that is at the cost of the adverse
effects fundamentally
quite marked hypotension and therefore
generally what we are going to use are
combinations of analgesics with these
years of injuries and notorious
the laboratory anesthetic has an
advantage over the injectable and
that is that although each animal has an
individualized response or the dose is
individual in  In this sense, the range that
we have within the same species and
more center in the same strain is
relatively constant or varies
relatively, that is to say, for example, those
uranus
have that the power that the value that
determines the minimum constitutionality
is 1.3 percent and  really
simply 1.1 as we see
approximately this level up to a
level that does not reach approximately 1.6 percent
what we always try to do is a
synergistic effect between drugs
if for example this line I am marking
here indicates
the equivalent anesthetic effect we see
that  If we administer, for
example, a drug from 1 to a
very high dose
p  We can produce an anesthetic effect
that would be indicated at this point
but at the cost of side effects
derived from those such
high doses of the drug from an iso-citizen example,
high doses, on the contrary,
if we want to combine it with very high doses of morphine
, which will  On the
contrary, we need to say more
than we need, we are going to find
adverse effects and probably the
anesthetic effect at the same time is
not adequate enough, which is ideal,
the ideal is to try to find the minimum
dose of isoflurane and no dose
of morphine.  that allows us along this
line to achieve the same objective,
therefore we guarantee the anesthetic effect
but have a negative impact on the
animal
and this is what we always want when
we do a combination of drugs
during anesthesia and in the case
of probably extension to the still
no some flexibility
here for example we see the impact it
has
on ob data  taken from different
studies carried out in recent years
in our laboratory such as
low concentrations, for example, of
opioids such as butanol,
buprenorphine, fentanyl, gathering people in
the market to produce a
reduction in needs and their figure is
not on the order of 30 to 50  kitchen
if we increase the dose
what we are going to see is that the range can
be increased not with phono executor
curiously there is an effect called
ceiling also that we add the dose we
are not able to potentiate the
isoflurane effect but it is curious that
we can obtain with drugs such as
zentani run it and morphine
methadone another manuel we can obtain
reductions in
anesthetic and laboratory needs of the order of
60 to 100 percent, which indicates that
we are going to have greater particular stability,
that is, our animals are
going to be in a situation of risk
smaller which is always interesting
another interesting aspect is also
important  First of all, we assume that when we
administer an analgesic we are going to
obtain analgesia and fortunately that is
the case in most cases.
The curious thing is that not
necessarily in all cases here,
for example, in another study carried out by
our laboratory, we administered
hostage rats and fentanyl and  continuous inclusion
doses of 120 micrograms per kilo and per
hour and typically it will produce a
reduction in the needs and those
organs of an average of 20 percent
this arrangement of a curve of dice
these are data obtained from about
200 with about  200 animals in some
cases the effect was very powerful in fact
we could practically reduce
the vaporizer to half the dose that we
administered the vaporizer but the most
striking of all is that at the
opposite extreme we observed how in some cases
in some animals the kingdom compared  The
nest not only did not produce an
analgesic effect but increased the
needs of our and condemner  io
this can occur as we will see
later in the case of use
another thing that we generally do is
combine other drugs to enhance
one of them and if we go back to the
previous example in another similar study we see
how trying and it will not produce this
reduction  between 20 and 30 percent
of this study approximately, but
as the co-administration of metamizole, for
example, metamizole, its widely used drug,
for example, in some
European countries such as
Spain-France, will produce a
potentiation of the reducing or
saving effect of  in this circulatory system
while, for example, if we do not
administer any drug, we see that
the rhein 30 emilio actually loses
potency even though we are administering
a continuous infusion, therefore not
all combinations will be equally
effective, the logical thing would be to try to
find those that produce a
more appropriate or more powerful effect, for
example, and to stop a very well-known
drug  Acid like paracetamol of
acetaminophen in the USA or in other countries
that also produce potentiation,
although more moderate compared
to it.
One way to maintain an
intraoperative analgesic effect is the
administration by continuous infusion of
drugs. There are many combinations of
drugs that can be administered by
this route and that they always try to reduce
the doses of other drugs that
animals typically administer,
inhalational anesthetics such as
ashura, as we have said here, for example,
we see that after administration, for
example, of an induction with propofol
and against cni we can do it
maintenance either with propofol at 0.4
milligrams per kilo or with other
drugs, in this case, use a little
strong or also agree on continuous infusion.
The idea is that these combinations of
continuous infusion maintain stability
of blood plasma levels and
therefore the level  of reduction should
be stable throughout  Of all the
surgical and anesthetic procedures,
for example, we use
in dogs combinations called ml
knf of Camu, which are well known in the
veterinary clinical field, come from the
use of drugs such as morphine,
hence eme lidocaine or ketamine,
and instead of flec to what  I am going to
use morphine fentanyl.
Carrying out this combination is very
simple.
We are going to select a
500 milliliter serum in which, for example, if
we have to decide to use thermal
fentanyl, lidocaine, ketamine, we are going to
administer 150 micrograms of fentanyl,
this supposes the administration of
We are going to administer 5 vials of cayenne noise.
If, for example, we
obtain 5 percent of it, we have to use an
ampoule of milliliters and finally
ketamine, if the concentration is 100
milligrams per milliliter, it is enough to
administer one milliliter
once we have this combination
.  we can manage it in such a way
that we give an initial ball  ia some
loading dose of 3000 liters per kilo followed
by a continuous infusion of three points
because for now I prefer an animal
of 10 kilos the infusion rate
would be 30 milliliters for
approximately
what is curious above all is that this
combination in dogs allows to reduce
the needs in extinction to thorium
of 20, 50 percent, even 70
percent, on the other hand, with the tests that
we have carried out in pigs, we have seen
that the degree of reduction is very low
once it is null, therefore we cannot
ensure that these combinations  be
appropriate if we move to another
species in which its effect has not been proven,
here we would see, for example, a
similar example in which we compare dogs and
cats and curiously see that a dose,
for example, of hostage and fentanyl at 15
micrograms per kilo could in  the dog
reduces the needs of its citizen
approximately 50 percent but in
the cat only half 23
percent
therefore ta  This gives us an idea that
we always have to be cautious
when using these combinations if we
do not have a specific study, other
drugs that we can study in people
who are studying to use, for example,
lidocaine,
for example, once is 50 micrograms per
kilo minute.  to obtain a 15%
reduction and we are going to double the effect even more
if we quadruple the
hydrogen dose, for example. Therefore, the idea
is that we have with other
combinations available other drugs that we can
incorporate as perioperative analgesics,
one way to facilitate it is to have  of
resources, for example, here
I would recommend I have taken a look at this web page
of ww tubulares executor I left a
support group for intense and
veterinary analgesia where it comes to part of a lot of
information related to the
administration of
analgesics included many tables in
excel or format  of another type in which they
indicate how to make a calculation of
administration  ion of these drugs
continuously in different species
, therefore I recommend your visit.
We have already said before that analgesics
we assume are simple analgesics and
one of the aspects that we are seeing
lately in studies that
we have also carried out in our
laboratory and specifically in  rats is
that when we administer
continuous infusion of fentanyl, for example,
we hope that the effect that it will
produce depending on the dose will be a
reduction in camps with respect to
the basal value that approximately,
as we have commented, 20 percent,
even 40 percent.  The curious thing is
that even maintaining the continuous infusion
at the same rate of drug administration,
we see how as
time goes by the effect is
reduced, that is, the efficacy of the
opioid analgesic decreases, a
phenomenon that, sorry, we
normally call opioid tolerance and
The curious thing about it all is that this phenomenon
is very
this effect quickly if we see the
time scale at the bottom
we see that the halving of the efficacy of
the analgesic occurs in
just an hour and a half
when we start the infusion of the drug
we will see how we have a
powerful lugano reduction but that  this
reduction is only half when
approximately 90 minutes have passed
another way of looking at it is also what is
the impact of the simple
administration of a single dose so
different from nilo that it probably has
an analgesic effect in a few minutes on
the pain threshold  the mechanical threshold
of the bolus profile if we
apply pressure to the plantar area of ​​a
rat we will see that these rats will
tolerate a defined basal pressure
after administering reviven danilo
a single dose by subcutaneous intraperitoneal route.
We have been able to observe and
we see here in  the graph using
the filaments of bonn fried as
during a period that goes from the day
to the  twenty-one days three weeks the
thresholds decrease
approximately 40 percent
this effect is also reproduced when,
for example, we use the randall technique the
randall test was
dictated it was dictated very similar and we see that
practically the response is the same
a considerable reduction in the threshold  of
the tolerance that the same rat has to
the same pressure that did not
bother it before and that now bothers it and this is
simply produced by the single
administration of the drug,
this means that the opioids are not adequate,
no, that is not really the factor or the
message that you want to give, we must continue
using them, it must be recognized that
these studies use animals that do not
have previous pain and it is considered that
an important factor is that the opium of
an analgesic is more effective. Good, it has
these processional effects in animals
that previously presented pain.  In other words,
when analgesic analgesic treatment is necessary, it
works better than
it happens with the saints constants
schools our videos
we have the cox cold and we also have
recently marketed rodena
coaching generally we are
having drugs that are
selective on cyclooxygenase they are
better than the previous ones in general they
have fewer side effects and
also have a great advantage almost all
the  Dosage regimen is every 24
hours, which makes
it quite simple to
administer from a logistical point of view compared to the previous ones,
but really, they all end up
doing basically the same thing, they
block oxygenation and with respect to
local and regional anesthesia and analgesia,
lately in the clinic we use a lot
what is called the administration of
a splash or simply bathing the
wound is probably more effective in
closing the edges of the wound and between,
for example, the muscle layer that we see
here in this rat and the skin layer,
once the skin is closed, introduce
a small amount of this if placed
or we can administer, for example,
drugs orally here we are going to see
a short video of what the
activity administration technique would be and
that we use in ruminants with
other
racing species this is a late video
logically because it is a little more
difficult in rodents
there are  There is a lot of information regarding the use of
epidural anesthesia. I think it does not make
sense to go into it simply that
we know the technique and that we not only
use local anesthetics but
also, for example, you can use
opioids or, for example, we can use
alpha 2 receptor agonists.
This is true.  These are ways that
can really help us with function that is sometimes
prolonged, simply remember that
when we administer a local anesthetic
for 10 vidal, we always indicate that the
duration is x time and final minutes,
but we must understand that
the maximum effect is really prolonged and
then falls  gradually for
example also this  In a study that
we carried out in dogs, we see, for
example, the administration of multivacaine
0.75 percent that we see here marked
in a blue square, will produce a
maximum analgesic effect
in all cases after 10
minutes and lasts up to 150 minutes
and progressively  It decreases
until the end. In all cases, the
animals recover sensitivity
after a few hours. If we use
lower concentrations of cocaine 0
5%,
the effects are less intense and of
shorter duration and the
lower concentration never really has a
depressant effect.  abolition of pain and
really the only thing it does is
mitigate pain, therefore we must
select how and when we use
each concentration.
In recent years,
more precise nerve block techniques have been developed
and specifically here we are going to
use the nerve echolocation technique
this  is based on the use well by
an electrical stimulator that produces  causes a
muscle contraction due to the activation
of the nerve when we are close to the
nerve with the needle or through an
ultrasound machine through which we
identify where the nerve is located
and around the nerve we are going to
inject the anesthetic obviously
we have a lot of precision we need
less amount of  anesthetic drug
therefore fewer side effects and
having such precision we have a
great efficacy in the effect therefore
in many cases it can be a good
alternative for refinement
many of the studies are
developed mainly in dogs
and data curiously a group that
has  developed to a great extent
and here basically if we wanted to
summarize what would be the procedures
that we would have to perform if
we had to ask the question of
what we would use for example for an
imaging procedure where there is no
pain we should probably
consider that a drug like
oriental painting co  In a few
Costa Rican characters it could be appropriate, but if we are going
to perform abdominal surgery,
the administration of a
combination of ketamine would probably
be appropriate in rodents,
on the contrary, if we are going to look for a
postoperative analgesia effect,
logically it would be a combination of
analgesics such as  meloxicam and someone
at the end, therefore, depending on
our objectives, we are going to
select the drugs and the
combination of them,
what we are really going to do is what
is called this city, it is a
combination of different drugs that
will allow us to  It is to obtain this
desired effect,
what we must always do is to
use the anesthetic, it is adequate, that is to
say, that the image does not respond
to the surgical stimulus. We already know that
we can use the technique in rodents
of the withdrawal reflex, not the power reflex,
through the thought of the finger.  or of the tail
and it really is a very suitable mechanism
for valuing  Prior to the start of
surgery, the level of analgesia, of
course, as analgesics can
cause side effects, we must not
forget also the use of
different piles that allow us to
evaluate which line of
inspiratory pressure due to the use of
opioids, continuous infusions, etc.,
etc.
in the  analgesic recovery really
sorry grace an analgesic anesthetic
we must do a good analgesic support it
should always be a routine
whenever we do any
procedure that is going to cause pain
typically we are going to incorporate an
anti-inflammatory our video here
determining our
research objectives and the limitations on
the results in some
experimental models that, for example,
can interfere, we should
probably look for an
alternative opioids are often an
alternative to the use of andy and
frank three of these videos but
we always keep in mind that  that it does not
replace it and that in fact they are
complementary and the maximum
analgesic efficacy will normally be
obtained when we make many
combinations
if we want to propose, for example, an
analgesic protocol that lasts, for
example, several days, the
use of charcoal will probably be meloxicam
once a day  the appropriate person and
probably combined during the
first day or the first hours with an
opioid such as buprenorphine or
work,
since both biotechnology or
dithering produces an
analgesia of about 6 or 8 hours in the first
case and from 12 to  24 hours in the second
case, therefore the kinetics in three in a
factor that we must always take into
account when deciding what drugs
we are going to use,
what other drugs or what other
postoperative options we have before we have
indicated the damage of the wound once
wound sheath alternative that is
something as simple as when we are
closing the surgical wound we
simply deposit  taking a small
amount of local anesthetic bobby the
fall normally better than lidocaine
because the duration is usually between 2 and 4 times longer
but another way is also to place a
catheter and in this way what we do
is soak the surgical wound
periodically, for example after a
imputation that it is a very painful procedure,
what we can do is
administer the microperforated catheter through this catheter
inserted into reality,
administer the
local anesthetic every six hours, pídeles patches have also been
used in recent years
, but their
design has really been for medicine  human and
therefore its use rather
its effectiveness has probably been
less than desired apart from the price
that
perhaps an advance in this sense could have is the
commercialization of a fentanyl
gel this gel is called will resort and is
distributed by the pharmaceutical company
of the  alcor is available both in the usa
I understand that also in canada and e  In
other European countries there has also been
a global launch in 2013 and
its application is very simple,
a volume of drug per kilo of weight is calculated and
perhaps the main one is administered
but it has difficulty is that it is not
recommended for animals that have  a
weight really less than 12 kilos for
the volume that must be administered
, therefore there are still no studies that
would be or have demonstrated the
efficacy
of small species such as
runners. The great advantage of administration
is that it is very simple  It obviously does not hurt, it
is deposited at the base of the
hair and the analgesia lasts four days
, therefore we have a
very prolonged energy coverage,
what happens if everything that we have
proposed that is apparently unreal does not
work, since we must permanently re-evaluate
for today, we would return to the
first  part of the conference, that is,
we must evaluate using tables
using scales if the analgesic regimen
that we have initially designed
one works if apparently
the results of said assessments or
scales are adequate we maintain the
pattern but if they indicate that there may
be we should modify
it appropriately therefore we have
different algorithms that
allow us in a relatively
It is easy to raise it with our
algorithm that we see here
and to finish you can simply
give an indication of where we can
find resources and here I suggest that
those who may be
interested can go to what we call
the web of pain the web of pain is
called ww dot  dolor animal punto de
rege is a web page that we have
developed in my center and where the
objective is basically to select
those referents that we consider most
relevant in the field of pain and
incidents in animals and that we can say to
present in a simple way
initially filtering but also  discussed in
many cases  sos and where we can find
from publications to videos, some
of them free access, other
resources such as the page
on continuous infusions, etc.,
etc.
that we can be interested
so much I encourage everyone
to enter the keywords
and get information and more
importantly that we receive the information
to the appropriate feedback to be able to
improve it
or let's say or increase it to dictate in
terms of its contents
and finally good  Well, they indicate that
we have, I think everyone knows it,
and very good references and many of
them curiously available on Google. It should
also be indicated that, for example,
all these books that we are seeing
that are marked on the right with what
is available in the
google books well many of the
The most interesting parts, for example,
the chapters on anesthesia in rodents,
for example, in Paul Breitner's book,
are not available, but in
any case, we can always
obtain interesting information and that is where
we can probably go into detail on
what is the best combination, the best
drug
to use in our animals
and nothing else for today for now at
least and thank you very much everyone for the
attention and we would be prepared
to see the questions and answers that
we may have so here we
have apparently received
4 answers to what I am seeing  Here
I am going to comment on them so the
first question, if I am able to
assess it correctly, Ignacio tells us,
please explain when you say
that certain anesthesias do not have
analgesic properties, for example
pentobarbital,
I will try to explain what when
we administered we did a test a long
time ago  quite a few years
in this case well I think I don't know  olo
question marx the gentle
let's say I think one of the
organizers of this event
is probably to highlight that
sometimes it can create confusion in this
situation what really happens is
that if we administer, for
example, promotion to pigs in
continuous infusion these apparently are
anesthetized
if we use the accessory finger
what will happen is that the pig
will typically withdraw the limb
as a demonstration reflex odor response
the withdrawal that we use
in rodents
if we increase the dose or
caution because it could be
insufficient then what  What is going to
happen is that the pig goes into apnea,
that is, it has a
very marked respiratory depression effect that
stops breathing, therefore we have to
start mechanical ventilation,
curiously, if we prick the
accessory finger again, what we are going to observe
is that the animal  continues to withdraw the
limb therefore it is an indicator
It is clear that there is a hypnotic effect of the
7 animal is asleep, it does not respond to
auditory stimuli, we indicate that it
probably does not respond if we touch it, it
does not respond at the moment we do
damage to it, it responds, therefore it is a
typically hypnotic effect and with little if
there is an analgesic effect.  It is true that we
cannot rule out that there is a slight
effect beforehand,
I do not know if I have just
translated for you in this way that pentobarbital
perhaps we cannot classify it
as a drug that is not going to produce an
analgesic effect because we
can really intervene only complete animals.
It has been done
in millions of animals probably in
some centers it was still being
done but it is true that the efficacy
is not very good and generally when an
animal responds sometimes when
we increase the dose we enter the
danger zone where the problems begin
respiratory depression effects
generally cardiovascular also
negative therefore  or they continue to order in
safety and at the same time guarantee
the need normally these drugs
tend to have poor analgesia because
probably saying that they are not
analgesic may not be the most
appropriate term but they are not given a
clear analgesic effect
there are other drugs that I clearly
don't know  If you have any doubts about it and if not, well,
we try to clarify later
on Laura Vanessa
and she asks us
I am completely ignorant on the subject
I don't think so my question is these
combinations of drugs are applied
in a single dose for each one
separately, generally we combine them
all  When we talk about the fact that we
administer that your limin
normally ends in one, they
are compatible drugs and it also has
an advantage, you don't have to prick
the animals twice, therefore I think that
even they will also thank
only the funds, also the
drugs again when  are
incompatible normally in some
warning and anesthesia  two the zeal
the usual thing here someone asks if there is a
possibility of establishing an
English version of the presentation well my
accent is probably the same as what
I have here but well I could have
devoured it and we can raise it we will see
how we can do it with the
organization
probably  also sorry it also
refers only to the slides it is
possible that in this case if they can be
raised I have some version and well
we wanted to know how we could
move it later the question is
the question marx asks me what
perioperative anesthetic and analgesic or
protocol he recommends for a disease
Parkinson's in a mouse model
Well, I figure that
the specific model should not see it and this is a
current problem, that is to say that the
disease has its particularity,
I have worked with many animal models
but not specifically with Parkinson's,
which I do  It is true, it is known to
information, for example, that anesthetics
c  Since inhalants have a
production such as beta amyloid and
therefore in susceptible patients who
could basically be neonates or
geriatrics it seems that there is
cognitive dysfunction in the
postoperative period probably associated with the
use of anesthetics in some cases
directly associated with the use of
anesthetics and  Therefore,
perhaps inhalational anesthesia
would not be the ideal drug, but I insist, these are
studies in very
specific situations and it is not an effect that is
clearly written.
Javier Benito asks us.
Have you said that the metallic has
more analgesic power than paracetamol?
any studies that indicate how
these anesthetics or analgesics
affect the cav in rats well what I
would have to say here is that it is also a
factor that depends on the dose we
have used specific things we have
seen an effect with a
very high dose of  metamizole and apparently the
effect is therefore ba  It is still more appropriate
than paracetamol or acetaminophen, but I
still believe that the important thing is to look for
those combinations of drugs that
enhance or enhance the effects that
we want in the United States, I get the feeling
that mentalizado is not a very
common drug, so  both acetaminophen
in general would be the standard drug in
europe we could use one of the two
combinations the one we have closest to hand
a logistical factor is always
important
another question that he also asks is
if he wants yes yes I think that in the
future there will be one  translation of the
methods of the sentence needs to
stylize the research really yes
and I think that the person who asks you g
de benito also has
information about the methods of evaluation of
internal thermal mechanical thresholds
what is called
quantitative sensory evaluation methods really
clearly they are going to be the most used in the future
because they are much
finer or fi  Based on the information we
obtain, the evaluations of
behavior are reliable, but there are few studies
and most of them have been developed
mainly in dogs and cats. We will
have to wait to see if the
effect can be reproduced in other
beings of interest, for example, to know two
ruminants. There are some studies.
students or rodents
another question from ángel naranjo who
asks us a greeting also how
ibuprofen works in water of life
in rodents I have always been very
critical of the administration of
drugs in the drink and it is for a reason
especially at the beginning or at the  start of
treatment, which is sometimes when
we are most interested, especially if it is peri-
operative because the pain is maximum
immediately after surgery and it
is that firstly the animals can drink
less and secondly when they
sometimes detect their strange taste and dominate the
drugs  are not
properly flavored animals tend to
reduce intake therefore the
difficulty  The main limitation is that it is possible to obtain
the adequate dose of the drug
if
pilot tests are previously carried out where it is shown
that the intake is adequate and it is assessed
or adjusted, since it can probably
work and I know that in some centers it
is not done for  So much so that I believe that it must be
valued in each case,
María del Mar Martínez, who asks us about
work with immunosuppressed mice that she
habitually anesthetizes with that,
citizen, I have no perceptible side effects,
which is that it would be
beneficial and to measure
one year before surgery and today
if the teacher  The good thing is that I
don't have noticeable side effects,
but fortunately
the dreamers are generally nothing, they are all
healthy animals, which means that the
impact that inhalational anesthetics can have
is offset by
the animal's own healthy physiology, so there
we have a great  advantage would not be the
same if we are talking about models
where the animal presents a  Depression
its functions due to the experimental model project
or the pathology that has been
induced would not be an important first aspect.
In any case, it would be good
to add an opioid if it goes away, although
if a painful procedure is going to be performed,
I think it should if we are
speaking of, for example, at work,
for example, for the induction of cancer, well,
it would be necessary to see the possible
interference that it could have in an
induction of cancer, for example, and if it
delays, I think that many times it is if there
is a delay, it would be very temporary
because the  evolution, for example, of the
tumor could be several days or
weeks while
the treatment from the first or second
as in each case and if the pain obviously
I think so
using this video and one child and
if the pain is also intense
together
there is one last question about  charo sánchez
also of level in barcelona
who comments that I administer the mouse 5
liters of a 50% ketamine
determines me for  reverse and to reverse
without microliters to start is correct
I need to know the concentration of which
also dominates because obviously it has
a predefined concentration and almost
certainly probably the
final concentration is for a dose
less in the order of 80 100 milligrams
wants ketamine really element
measure of the order  of a milligram kilo
probably irati stowaway typically it
is usually 2 it is five times higher than
the dose again and combines therefore
a milligram was used it would be
approximately 45 milligrams here
if they coincide with those doses and falls
within the range that is described the
size of the publications basically
I insist we can talk about it later
but now if I don't have the concentration
I can't determine
we have one last question in this case
from Ruth Molano from the University of
Miami who tells us in terms of
anti-inflammatory effects which
analgesics have the greatest
anti-inflammatory effect and  which less and  In
some experimental models it is
desirable to have a gesture with and not an
anti-inflammatory effect and
a final bolt is generally
recommended, other options can be recommended and in the opposite case,
in which a strong anti-inflammatory analgesic effect is desired, it
may really be
appropriate for us.
I believe that
we can answer  focus on the fact that there is a group of
anti-inflammatories, those of videos that
usually have an anti-inflammatory effect
that is understood to be similar, probably the
most depending on the dose and
therefore if we maintain the regimen in
maintenance that dose, therefore the
duration of the effect and  then on the other
hand we basically have
paracetamol of paracetamol the term
faith also does the brake in the usa it is
a drug that is not considered anti-
inflation they have this video
it is considered to be a lethy drug and
a fundamentally analgesic and
antipyretic effect therefore yes  we want to
eliminate the anti-inflammatory effect
could be an option the mor  fine is not
an articulator of our daily life
therefore it does not have the said effect
it would also be adequate and proportional
analgesia
both drugs acetaminophen and finally
meet 68 hours therefore it
would be convenient to establish an
administration regimen in that period sometimes
the written  of solutions for the double
no in the end but it does imply that it is not
a daily justification and that times and
its administration increases a lot
I think there are no more questions and
therefore nothing
thank you very much to all of
you who have been able to endure here until the end
In the end, I hope that it has not produced much
anesthesia and, well, it has opened up
any questions and contacts that there may
be from everyone. There is one more
final question from Matt Smith. There is also
some possibility to contact by
radio email for more questions or
issues. Well, I don't know if  I can write
something to everyone,
I'm going to answer here and I want to
put it in my email  I
am writing it in the lower part it
would be duárez ucm of the
complutense university of madrid
point 3
I have answered I think that maybe only
to one person but good if
the rest of the ear would be there and if not
well well then I will be delighted
through the  organization or another way
because it will also provide my
email to answer with the
questions are considered
thank you very much to all for all